weather to remind us of gloomier times
last winter when christmas was cancelled
tens of thousands of people died from
clovid and we found ourselves in a long
lockdown not an experience any of us
want to repeat and that means not
repeating the mistakes of christmas past
so what's the plan in essence we're
going to keep going we will continue to
offer testing we'll continue to urge
everyone to be sensible
we are confident in the vaccines that
have made such a difference
to our lives
and we're now intensifying that effort
offering jobs to 12 to 15 year olds on
the advice of the chief medical officers
and
for
over 50s and the
under 50s who are at risk or more at
risk we're now motoring ahead with the
booster program
and if that's not enough we will keep
further measures
in reserve
plan b
that could mean vaccine passports for
events a return to mandatory face
coverings workers could once again be
asked to work from home in the meantime
we are confident in the vaccines that
have made such a difference
to our lives the pm may be confident his
scientists are cautious anybody who can
say with confidence they know how this
is going to work over the next few
months has not fully understood i think
the range of possible ways this could
happen winter is coming and people
really should take this seriously
because i don't think you need a medical
degree to know that autumn and winter is
when respiratory viruses are hugely
advantaged an appointed message to the
pm if there's a need for plan b don't
delay if this goes in the wrong
direction and cases go up followed by
hospitalizations it's important that the
measures are put in place early enough
and they're significant enough thank you
the prime minister of the united kingdom
but this a plan for england as before
other nations go in their own way to
avoid any mistaken assumption it's
important for us to confirm that the
scottish government is not following
suit at this stage in england covered
passports for events remain a
possibility in scotland there'll be a
reality the prime minister is hopeful
that vaccines and the booster program
will get us through this second winter
of covid but he was at pains too to
avoid making any promises he didn't know
if he could keep be that on face masks
on passports even on the prospect of
another lockdown this a prime minister
who's perhaps learnt the lessons from
last winter and all those coveted
u-turns
promises end up broken but plans can
always be changed
tory mp's resistant to plan b but in
manchester people more amenable there's
no way you could do a lockdown but uh
social distancing could be a good idea
uh in terms of places like schools or
malls or restaurants i don't think i
want the social distancing to come back
but i'd prefer to wear the first masters
certain restrictions definitely
certainly a return to working from home
and certainly
certain social distancing masks public
transport for definite
christmas is normally something to look
forward to but last winter has left its
scars this year anticipation is mixed
with nerves beth rigby sky news
westminster